[Música]
[Aplausos]
não penso em conexão online
eu penso numa velocidade uma intensidade
imensa de fluxo de informação e
comunicação
mas eu penso que também essa mesma
velocidade pode gerar uma enorme falta
de profundidade por isso quero pedir a
licença pra vocês para usar uma palavra
em inglês porque hoje eu quero falar
aqui de conexão online
efe na vida real essa tecnologia de
ponta que oferece pra gente o olho no
olho
oferece pra gente a presença física e
que faz possível as conexões afetivas
reais e que elas que fazem possíveis a
transformações reais nas pessoas
há nove anos eu venho atuando
mobilizando comunidades para a
transformação social
venho empoderando eles e realizando
várias transformações pelo brasil e vem
sendo muito empoderada e transformada
por eles também têm muitas histórias
inspiradoras que eu já vi até hoje mas
eu quero escolher uma aqui para
compartilhar com vocês que aconteceu há
uns quatro cinco meses atrás no ceará
numa cidade chamada cumbuco
eu fui pra lá com uma grande amiga minha
companheira de ótimas aventuras para
realizar um projeto que a gente criou
juntas
a ideia era fazer um festival de
oficinas de educação ambiental e
valorização de cultura e identidade
local usando o esporte como principal
ferramenta de mobilização
detalhe desde que eu tenho uns três anos
eu sou estuprada por esportes e desde
que eu me descobri como empreendedora
social sempre foi o meu sonho de juntar
essas duas coisas
é incrível como hoje em dia a gente pode
inventar nossa própria carreira como a
gente pode juntar várias paixões e
chamar isso de trabalho
acho que a realização desse projeto lá
no ceará foi a concretização de um dos
maiores sonhos da minha vida
costuma fazer oficinas de audiovisual
com os jovens das comunidades para que
eles descubram os talentos que tem lá
talentos que estão sempre lá mas
raramente eles são valorizados e
reconhecidos ea gente acredita que
reconhecendo esses talentos a identidade
dessa comunidade se fortalece os laços
afetivos se fortalece e foi num
exercício como esse que os jovens do
cumbuco descobriram o pelicano que é um
pescador cearense com uma típica vida
solitária entre saídas para o mar
concertos de barco e muita cachaça nas
horas vagas ele estava pintando uma arte
numa jogada e os jovens ficaram
encantados com o que eles viram e ele
que nos últimos anos estava acostumado a
ser praticamente invisível para todo
mundo ao redor dele ficou super
emocionado ao ter o seu talento
reconhecido e valorizado
ele começou a participar das atividades
com a gente todos os dias participou do
mutirão de limpeza da praia ajudou na
reforma do container que viria ser um
ponto de cultura da comunidade
ele me contou as histórias da vida dele
por onde ele passou todas as idades que
ele morou com que ele trabalhou que ele
aprendeu e quando ele perguntou sobre a
minha vida eu confesso que fiquei um
pouco constrangida com a falta de emoção
da minha trajetória
afinal de contas nascida crescido em são
paulo uma estrutura familiar
formado em arquitetura atuando na área
social mais ou menos dez anos não
apareceu nada emocionante perto das
aventuras daquele homem pássaro e as
transformações internas pela qual ele
passou foram refletidas está na mente
então ele fez a barba trocou de roupa
cada dia ele aparecer com um presente
novo para a nossa equipe e quando ele
soube que é a foto dele com o talento
dele a estampar uma das paredes do
container
ele ficou tão emocionado que não só ele
falou que as lembrar desse momento pra
sempre como ele prometeu ajudar a manter
a praia limpa ea cultivar tudo que a
gente estava construindo
juntos e aconteceu mais ou menos assim é
essa fazer esse rapaz o meio onde estava
a chave 6 amigos ok show local dó
identidade única
as suas jogadas que eu posso fazer
nenhum eu vou começar a juntar todos os
cocos na praia porque eu ia voltar um
pouco papo que a praia está suja
esse é uma ótima coisa vamos lhe pai
embora o que vocês vão ficar
não é fácil ajudar é só pra mim a qual
sempre é o que é hoje e melodia da minha
vida ser o toque especial meu e do
pelicano que a gente desenvolveu nesse
medo o que será que a gente pode
aprender com tantos pelicanos que a
gente encontra pelo brasil quem será que
sai mais transformada de uma experiência
como essa que cada comunidade que eu
tenho a oportunidade de mergulhar numa
realidade diferente me conectar com esse
lugar é tanto aprendizado pessoal e
profissional
a gente que trabalha no campo
diretamente assim com as pessoas com
cada um dos seus mundos cada pessoa um
universo completo
a gente está sempre pronto para ser
surpreendido
e é com isso em mente que eu quero
trazer para vocês cinco ferramentas
tecnologias poderosíssimas de
mobilização comunitária que talvez vocês
até já tem
ouvido falar
essas tecnologias elas são tão poderosas
que acho que até hoje eu não conheci uma
maneira mais eficiente de mobilizar
pessoas e todos aqui nessa sala tem
acesso ilimitado a esses recursos
elas são tão poderosas que o movimento e
o resultado que acontece sempre nos
surpreende
elas são tão óbvias que às vezes a gente
até esquece que elas existem
então quero começar falando da primeira
ferramenta que é ou não julgamento que a
gente está com o coração aberto
a gente está pronto para se relacionar
com pessoas de origens realidades e
opiniões diferentes das nossas às vezes
muito diferentes das nossas
não julgar significa você criar um
ambiente acolhedor para que a pessoa se
sinta à vontade para manifestar a quem
ela é de verdade para ela poder se ela
mesma e com isso ela querer fazer parte
de alguma coisa que querer oferecer o
que ela tem de melhor para essa coisa é
você ter a certeza que todo ser humano
tem o seu valor e que ninguém é melhor
do que ninguém
a gente só diferente e assim eu vou pra
nossa segunda ferramenta que é a
curiosidade que tem 1.000 assuntos
infinitas maneiras de cada um demonstra
a sua curiosidade
mas uma coisa é fato quanto mais a gente
aprende mais a gente quer aprender
parece que isso é curioso um vício do
tipo você se exercitar na academia assim
você vai exercitando e fica cada vez
mais curioso e interessado em ver que
tem um monte de coisas para descobrir
pelo mundo e se você não pratica você
enferruje sem essas duas tecnologias
eu jamais teria sequer trocado 18 um
pelicano não ia saber nada sobre a
história dele não ia descobrir sobre a
arte dele ea perder a oportunidade de no
mínimo saber muito sobre a realidade de
muitos brasileiros
e assim a gente vai pra terceira
ferramenta que é a escuta ativa
não é à toa que a gente tem dois ouvidos
e uma boca
acho que é porque talvez muitas vezes é
mais importante a gente escutar do que
fala e olha escutar e ouvir
são conceitos muito diferentes quando a
gente escuta ativamente a gente escuta o
nosso corpo inteiro a gente coloca
nossos cinco sentidos a serviço da quilo
que a pessoa está contando pra gente
então nessa foto por exemplo dá pra
imaginar que esse rapaz ele é do
zimbábue está em cubatão sem falar uma
palavra de português se conectando com
essa senhora da comunidade
acho que é um ótimo exemplo de que como
quando você ativa a sua sensibilidade
sua real vontade de se conectar com as
pessoas
a linguagem é só uma das maneiras de
fazer isso e que essa conexão pode ir
muito além das palavras é assim com os
ouvidos abertos a gente vai pra nossa
quarta ferramenta que é o afeto o afeto
é conectar os corações é você praticar
sua presença
você está lá por inteiro ouvindo o que
você está a pessoa te contando o que
você tá experience ando o afeto na
verdade é uma via de mão dupla porque
também se você tenta conversar com
alguém compartilhar alguma coisa ou
fazer algum convite sem afeto
dificilmente as pessoas vão topar elas
vão me acho que alguém outro pode fazer
isso ou não atrasado
ai meu telefone sempre vai ter uma
desculpa então um bom exemplo disso é
esse mutirão de limpeza da praia que a
gente fez isso quando a gente faz isso
com afeto pode ser uma oportunidade uma
experiência incrível e inesquecível sem
afeto só mais uma tarefa mais ou menos
chata e acho que as chances de
engajamento é quase zero e que abrir o
coração e ouvido pra se conectar com as
pessoas só época
cível quando a gente pega a quinta
ferramenta que é a enxergar a abundância
abundância aquele papo de enxergar o
copo meio cheio encontrar sempre um
aprendizado em uma situação desafiadora
é valorizar o conhecimento informal é
acreditar na potência de um grupo de
pessoas reunido que acredita em fazer
alguma transformação enxergar a
abundância é saber que a mudança já tá
acontecendo e que se a gente quiser não
só a gente pode ser parte da solução
como a gente tem muito a oferecer
quando eu comecei a pensar que eu falar
aqui pra vocês eu estava com essa idéia
da tecnologia sendo a vilã quadro que a
culpada de todos os nossos problemas da
modernidade mas entende que não entende
que na verdade a gente escolheu abrir
mão de muitas coisas para conseguir
universalizar essa tecnologia e que
muitas vezes essas coisas podem fazer
falta
as conexões online elas precisam ser
acompanhadas das conexões online
efe a vida real precisa de conexões
reais
é disso que nossa alma se alimenta no
então acho que quanto mais tecnologia
conecta online mas conexão online efe a
gente precisa
mas olho no olho a gente precisa sem
conexão real a gente se deprime
quantas histórias nem a gente acabou de
ouvir de casos de doenças psíquicas que
vem nessa nossa era pós internet essa
modernidade toda pode ser bem perigoso
tem um estudo do banco mundial da década
de 90 que fala que o sentimento de
pertencer a uma comunidade faz com que
as pessoas tenham a ter vidas mais
felizes mais saudáveis vivem em
comunidades mais estáveis e serem mais
solidários
esse estudo também fala que a confiança
é uma das características mais
importantes senão a característica mais
importante pra fazer um senso de união
de uma comunidade confiança o que dá
liga
e refletir um pouco sobre esse estudo
sobre minha própria prática de criar
elos de confiança para conseguir
mobilizar pessoas
eu consegui entender que o que a gente
vem fazendo é muito precioso e muito
simples ao mesmo tempo que essas cinco
ferramentas que eu trouxe pra vocês
foram essenciais para eu criar a própria
rede de de confiança e conseguir
expandir nossas ações pelo brasil
assim tão são tanto os depoimentos
tantos momentos incríveis que a gente
passa que me transformaram transformam
tanta gente pelo brasil que só me fazem
acreditar que cada pelicano transformado
é um potencial agente transformador que
a gente pode despertar essas pessoas com
ações muito simples isso estou aqui hoje
que tenho algo para compartilhar com
vocês é porque eu fui muito transformada
nesse processo
na verdade ainda torcendo porque ele é
um processo muito profundo e é constante
eu posso dizer que eu me sinto muito
realizada de poder juntar minhas paixões
chamar isso de trabalho e agir para
manifestar o meu processo
meu propósito no mundo e vocês o que
vocês acham que é necessário para
despertar dentro de cada um de nós esse
potencial de ser um agente transformador
[Aplausos]
[Música]